ready this is tia
[Music]
and this is tamara this is the murderer
see this man
which one is it hi this is your ace
roving reporter
hi jackie harry well i'm doing a new
show this season
along with tim reed and it's called
sister sister it's for abc
and what it's about is two twin
daughters
he adopted one at birth i adopted the
other at birth
and we're in a department store and they
see each other
dad mom
that girl has my face they instantly
fall in love oh this is my sister i miss
her i miss it but the problem is i can't
stand
tim reed's character and he can't stand
me i'm from the detroit projects and
he's
rich and i have i have a little bit of
class a little bit
oh here he is this is tim reed you know
and from wkrp
frank's place yeah you can come in my
set wait wait did you tell him this was
my house
yeah yeah said it was your house i mean
it's not like i can go to school and
grab some boy and say hey you edited you
better take out my daughter
kenna and they're doing a scene now i'm
not in this scene i don't know why
i guess cause they were in school i
can't quite i'm too old for school or
something but i'm trying to get in the
scene
oh here's one of our stars this is
tamara murray hello
where's us is oh she's in the bag
well they look just alike but i want you
to see the difference you can't really
tell
but i know them this one has a little
gleaming around the other one
has a little gleam in the rye
[Laughter]
this is his couch that's his chair
and working with jack k has been one of
the most pleasurable experiences of my
life did i say that right
was that what you sorry just to make
sure i hadn't no we need a little more
there is constant constant tension
between
she and i we don't know what it is yet
we don't know
we don't know if it's just plain hate
there's just constant plain hate
i got three gift certificates for beauty
makeovers
you need three huh this was my kitchen
but no longer is it my kitchen now
this is my kitchen now is what he's
saying although i don't cook
okay no here's something fun here's
something fun yes this is the best part
that i've never seen
a little space maker radio i i think
she's trying to get a commercial with ge
well to tell you the truth i have a
little trouble talking to boys
really i have trouble keeping quiet my
color
is like this in my room my cup we have a
vanity but
not that big yeah yeah but it's great we
we don't have posters or anything my
bed's messier than
her and as you can see look tia's is
tidy you know it's very neat
and smears is
[Music]
and this is a real refrigerator it's
really on
see how big it is he has no food for us
none look at that
mustard yogurt that's what he eats is
fabulous
fabulous kitchenaid he has a lot of
money really a wonderful set dishwasher
everything
it's a workable kitchen which means that
i'm not using it because i don't cook
wait wait wait a minute that's my tuna
needs more mail
oh those are our favorite groups yeah we
love them they love them
yeah they're good i really like tlc and
and development i like too
[Laughter]
i mean eric's not that cute right he's
gorgeous i know
i love you jackie she's the best the
best i've ever met
are you guys having fun on the show oh
yeah
don't they look pretty thank you and i
want you to know
i'll say this on public tv this was
their idea to do this show
and they have me as their mother and
timmy's their father
from the top everybody